[Music]
Runk hello
hello
hello hello
will
hello hello it is truly uncr anyway go
ahead hello UNC crankable anyway okay go
ahead do the intro it's episode 90 and
guess what it is December 31st and guess
what that is it is New Year Year's
[Music]
Eve New
Year a drunk elephant uh welcome to
Lifeline is the last episode of the Year
2023 tomorrow if you're watching this on
the day of its release is the beginning
of the year 2024 and guess what you
should do in that year the very first
thing not that the very first thing you
should do if you haven't already if you
have done this already you're the
greatest person in the world if you
haven't done it you can still be the
greatest person in the world by going to
do it now patreon.com Lifeline luxury
sign up for Lifeline luxury it is the
second Greatest Show on Earth after this
show which is Lifeline but also I'm on
tour brand uh new material from not from
grower die a different different stuff
doing all new stuff can't bring myself
to do the old stuff I get bored with it
whatever hey w uh Bria California anyway
I'll be there I'll be in Sacramento I
will be in Phoenix I will be in El Paso
Albuquerque uh Kona BC Vancouver so many
places kitner Rochester New York Houston
Texas go to chris.com there's a lot of
uh dates out there nor for Virginia
Durham Corpus chrisy Houston yeah all
right so uh that's that and also if you
want to send in a video here click the
link below uh and uh also send a thing
for Matt private record private
record.com got the podcast the private
record solo podcast coming out real soon
you're GNA love it uh go follow it on
Instagram and Tik top Tik Tok YouTube
Tipp top tippy top tip tiping and so the
one-onone advice sessions with Matt at
mat.com and the merch Lifeline merch.com
so look we did the holidays and here we
go we have another one I you know I've
talked about this on my I think on my
podcast congratulations but uh all the
holidays are smashed together not like
well that's Jesus shouldn't have been
born so close to New Year's Eve you mean
Horus you mean Jesus should have had the
presence of mind to be born right after
the pilgrims and Indians broke bread you
mean Horus and right before the new year
you mean Horus Horus Grant no not way
later Horus Grant was the Egyptian god
that W uh died on December 22nd and and
Rose back from the dead on December 25th
and there were three kings with him and
he had 12 followers and disciples and it
is the story basically of Jesus only
happened 3,000 years before Jesus High
yeah but the Epic of Gilgamesh I mean
every one of those stories is the same
there's flood there's the you know it's
the baby and Horus was the first
documented Immaculate birth I understand
it from a virgin he was born from a
virgin was born from a virgin hey would
you look at that they're also similar
all the abrahamic religions and also all
the religions before entering the age of
Aquarius Christ I mean stop saying Horus
Christ hor Christ and we are entering
Aquarius the age of Aquarius and we are
doing that in
200200 and once that happens we will
have a new deity to worship and that's
what will absolutely happen I've seen
way too many conspiracy theory doc dude
you are just off the deep end stop I
won't watch different stuff but that's
actually true
though read I do read this is what I get
the information from but read like a
book not
some
absolute batshit insane website that no
one's ever heard of you sight dude what
I'm saying is when the age of Aquarius
comes well I'm starting to sound like a
crazy what does that even mean dude
you're like you're like the Pisces seea
dude and seea the most sea ever okay
Moses died then Jesus happened and after
Jesus dies is going to be a new deity
worst history lesson of all time okay
stop saying a horist Christ Horus Christ
Horus Christ Horus T Christ Horus Horus
Tyrone Christ you better call tyone
Horus
Christ hor you saying Horus Horus Horus
like H O R Us s though not Horus a h o r
a s e oh God no not Horus I'm saying it
so he'll understand what I'm saying but
it's Horus is the H O R Us Horus I don't
know how to spell it but it's the guy
with the [__] eagle head and he's
Egyptian dude yeah Horus Grant who
played for the Bulls in the '90s the
same guy dude teammates with Harold
Miner no it's not
him okay Herold Miner won the Sam dunk
contest and he was absolutely [__] onito
not the Chicago Bulls was on the Chicago
Bulls with Michael Jordan Scotty pimp
Scotty pimp pimp was horis Grant the one
with the face mask thing yeah dude he
was the man like like it's a horror
movie why do they wear that [__] why did
basketball wear that I think it's oh
it's cuz Vis they have vision problems
no their nose you're talking you're
talking nose it's when they have a nose
thing no Horus Grant had this just goles
oh you're right yes I'm talking about
not that that that is right I got it I
got it mixed up but what is the thing
with the glass on their face a nose that
was broken recently or something like
that on your face wow yeah that is crazy
it's really sensitive cartilage you can
bang it again no I understand but just
don't play right well if you understand
then don't ask you well you have to play
understand after you told me oh okay
yeah but don't but you have to play
because if you're the man and your team
needs you you have you can't be like oh
my face is going to maybe you got to put
the mask on and get and suit up suit
up got to get Zed up from the feet up
suit up
okay all right well Harris Grant was a
good basketball player but he got
forgotten because of Michael Jordan and
Scotty Pippen and that's okay dude how
about Scotty Pippen and Michael Jordan
in like a loggerhead situation you know
Michael Jordan's son yeah you know about
this yeah I do did we talk about this on
the no we did not talk about on the show
but I'm I'm I'm well I'm up on current
events Jordan's son events is either
engaged to or dating or maybe even
married to Scotty Pippen's ex-wife
Scotty Pimpin Pimpin booya booya and
booya know this no see and even Michael
Jordan's like nah that ain't cool isn't
that weird even Michael Jordan's like
don't do that his son is yeah Micha
Michael basketball Jordan um it's uh
whatever somebody Jordan let me let me
see yeah and he's he's younger obviously
and Scotty he's really really handsome
is he obviously Michael Jordan is so
handsome no Michael Jordan's fine
looking dude I think Michael Jordan is
so handsome really yeah oh I mean I
would never say he's not a fine looking
guy but I think Michael Jordan is
absolutely one of the best looking like
major uh uh athletes of all time said
that's crazy Scotty Pippen's son no
no Michael Jordan's son the only person
we said is dating or maybe even married
to Scotty Pippen's
ex-wife yes they're they're they're
they're intimate together don't stop
even say dating or married just pick one
you
know Lana what's her name he had it up
and then he ruined
it oh wow Michael Jordan son is good
looking Marcus Jordan and Lara Pippen 25
years after Michael Jordan and Scotty
Pippin won their Michael's son Marcus
and Scotty X wife oh have a wedding yeah
dude they have a wedding in the works
and apparently Michael Jordan is like
not in they're like TMZ asked him or
whatever and he's just like that's
[__] up I say that's [__] up but you
know what I mean look how handsome his
son is yeah he's a good looking dude huh
and Larsa Pippen looks more like uh Mr
Potato Head she's pretty much low Kim
and white makeup but I look at all the
random parts that were assembled on her
face that nose is is cre she must be B
she must be bad in real life the lips
look
like they're just injected with every
possible thing she must be bad look how
[__] sick ass Michael Jordan's son
that is though so all right so there's
so there you go that's wild yeah Michael
Jord is good looking look Michael Jour
is so but to say he's one he's the one
of the best looking Major League major
athletes no that's crazy name two that
are more handsome than him seriously
yeah go ahead well first of all there's
so many baseball ones so name one
there's many many many footb name two
that are more handsome than Michael
Jordan I know it's subjective but oh
yeah obviously Tom Brady sure I mean I
don't agree but I totally get why
someone Steve Young
Steve
uh uh oh what's his name from uh the guy
who has 900 kids from um yeah obviously
he's hot because he's been banging
ringing um the the Ty what's what's his
name Ty tyell Owen what sport oh
Terell Owen that guy's major handsome no
come on oh come on bro you know who
really handsome was really handsome a
lot of quarterbacks were handsome right
Joe Montana I mean sure joth was
handsome Joe namoth was handsome yeah
yeah Joe Joe Montana's
okay yeah no Michael Jordan Michael Jord
both the same Michael Jordan's mad
handsome dude did you guys say Tom Brady
already yeah we did that was the first
one we said um uh uh who's the running
back uh Barry Sanders is really
good-looking more than Michael Jordan I
don't know I mean he's well he doesn't
look so good there oh no you know what
I'm not I'm not talking about Barry
Sanders I'm talking about um the one in
the other one EMT Smith EMT Smith he
yeah he that's who I meant
but who Tony cusa Tony larusa Tony Lusa
dude um uh not Dennis Eckersley was
really good-looking get
the [__] out of here I Tony Lusa you
know no yeah a lot of Dennis sley look
up Dennis
sley Dennis e c k e r s l e there you go
yeah come on that guy was good looking
that's a good looking dude he had a Vibe
but he wasn't yeah I guess yeah oh oh oh
oh yeah the e was hot dude the Steve
saxs was really
hot the hottest Todd zal was the hottest
he says you know what's his name Steve
saxs s a s ax and go go his name is
almost sex sex but with an a uh and then
go s go
young it'll come up he's a good look old
guy yeah
here we go oh let's see let's see let's
see the bat one that one that
one player profile on the left though
not on the left you're right but right
there yeah so there you go dude I mean
there's many many more but to say
Michael Jord that's you're only saying
that cuz he's you know what you're a hoe
people act like Derek Jeter is like dude
he's so ugly Dereck Jeter is a very
good-look Guy what it's his
eyes No Cap BR you're out of your no cap
that that that's crazy dude dere jeto is
a good-looking dude you're crazy you've
never been honestly
you have never been more wrong that's
crazy dude Derek Jeter he F he he's he's
good he's got the sauce you think he's
better looking than Michael Jordan I do
yeah when he was young you talk about
mind is shattered dude you talk about
young it doesn't matter anytime he was
never better looking than Michael J what
about this uh Pete sis Andre AGI okay
well you're talking tennis tennis is
like the hottest guys look at dark J's
wife dude Nadal Federer
sis look at his L about hockey players
dude hockey you're forget dude you're
crazy you're out of your element look at
D jer's wife bro I don't oh yeah I know
D Jet's a hot wife he's worth $800
million I know I know I know I get it I
get it I get it [__]
anyway uh Michael Jordan is a fine
looking guy but I would not say he's the
we're talking about it too much but I
would not say he's one of the best
looking athletes no way I love the way
Michael Jordan looks okay you know
physically
physically physically I love the way he
looks that's F that that's the only way
you can like someone looks is physically
I'm just I'm just someone I like the way
he looks emotionally you can't say that
I I just mean like on I don't mean like
on the court when he's in when he's in
motion I'm talking about physically
still images I love the way Michael
Jordan looks get it all right I get it
all right I get it my baby start um and
on the heels of that let's start with
the advice okay cool I guess I'll start
with the
advice uh hey Chris hey Matt hello um
try to make this fast so I'm such a
goofy person when I am by myself uh I
love who I am when I'm by myself I make
myself laugh and like I don't care who I
am and then all of a sudden when I get
into groups of people even with my
husband or whatever I like I get really
quiet and shy and awkward but like I
want to be a weirdo I want to be the
weirdo that I am and I want to be who I
am in front of people but I don't know
how to start that with people that I
already know cuz I can't be weird and
quiet one day and then all of a sudden
be weird and crazy so what is your
advice for slowly taking steps to be who
I am around the people that have got me
forever you overthinking it huh thank
you I love you bye you're overthinking
it though not that it's not valid
totally yeah right okay but you're just
overthinking it and it's making it worse
to overthink it is making it worse
that's true of almost every single thing
honestly okay but but not but not
everybody overthinks things and I'm
saying this is she is is what she's
doing over what I'm saying is
overthinking things almost always makes
things worse right got you okay cool so
so that's the way we should have said it
right but you didn't say that exactly
what I said anyone who has questions
about it can rewind and see exactly what
I said which is exactly that so uh yeah
I I actually totally get it not in the
way of like I want to be my true self
and it's weird but like I've had the
experience of being like I've changed or
I believe I've changed and people who
know me know version of me that they
insist on being the case and I feel like
I've grown in a different way than like
they see me because they've known me and
that you know you when you know someone
you come to expect behavior from them
and it can be hard to be the way you
want to be and be seen as such versus
their ongoing expectation of what
they've always thought you to be so I
can relate in that sense but it the
truth is the only doesn't matter ins
and- out specifics Nuance don't really
matter all that matters is you have to
act the way that feels natural to you
and right to you regardless of what
people's expectation of you are even if
it's very very very different right
that's it there's no other like you
could go on and on about it and talk
about your specific case it doesn't
matter like the only way to solve this
scenario or issue problem is to act the
way you feel is most aligned with the
way you are and the way you want to be
even if people are like oh
that's really different at first they'll
get used to it if they're really your
friend they'll get used to it I think
she's expressing some sort of
uncomfortability though is what that
when she's doing it it feels inauthentic
even though it's authentic because she's
around people and it gets and she gets
all bunched up about it which I do
understand but I would say that which
would be another symptom of overthinking
it right yeah but I would yeah I would
say that also with age it it it gets a
little easier I don't know how old she
is but you know I think that like cuz I
was like that in my
20s um also putting yourself in
situations where that's hard for you
makes it easier you know it's like when
I do stand up and I would bomb I'd get
better because I would just be like oh
this is what bombing is who gives a [__]
and then you know you you end up going
on stage and you make you know you and
you and you figure it out and they don't
sniff that fear from you so you're you
unapologetically you know what I'm
saying I do I don't know if it applies
to her but I do yeah I don't know I have
something that halfway applies as well
too I remember dude I remember the day I
became no longer shy what I REM I
distinctly remember the day it happened
I was the cross the crossing guard at my
elementary school I was in fourth grade
and the crossing guard who I saw every
day he'd walk me across the street when
I would go to walk home from school he
knew me and he knew me as like a really
quiet shy kid and I had this friend who
was the opposite of that and I think it
was the reason I was drawn to he was so
unabashedly himself all the time and he
was a really wild kid and funny kid I
thought at the time and when he when
this crossing guard would see us
together I assumed he thought we were
both like that but in reality it was
just my friend this day I was alone and
I remember thinking I'm going to act the
way I feel is more aligned with who I
really am in front of this guy because
there's no Stakes I don't care what this
guy thinks uhhuh but I was shy to
everyone in the world including this guy
so I was going to test it out on this
guy wow and I started being like you
know doing I don't even remember what I
was doing I remember I started I think
penis I started peeing all over the road
and on him and I was like being silly
and goofy and it's just me I realized
like there are no consequences it's
totally fine to either be shy or super
outgoing and silly and goofy and
honestly from that day on I was no
longer a naturally shy kid waa how old
were you I was in fourth grade I don't
know that's 10 or 11
isn't that weird I don't that's crazy I
remember I used to be shy I see it in
Calvin now you know Billy's only eight
months old so I don't really see it but
uh I see Calvin being shy and it's
interesting well here's the thing I know
I was cripplingly shy so I I know I was
wary of that so I was on the lookout for
it so when he started talking to people
I would make sure that I was with him
and I say it's okay why don't you say hi
to that person and tell them and when
somebody says what's your name I say
tell them your name I don't say it you
know it's okay tell them and and now
he's you know I don't know if you could
say a four-year-old I don't know if he's
outgoing or not for a four-year-old but
he'll go up and he'll be like you know
he's less shy than I was oh that's good
and and and and you know part of it is
because probably he he has some of
Kristen in him but like a lot of it is I
think because I led with you know
me uh knowing how I was and how it was
hard for me as a kid how scared I was
cuz I was always scared of everything
you know and I don't want I don't wish
that on you're huge
[__] true that you were a giganto [__]
so I wouldn't say giganto you were you a
a giganto little wussy baby boy okay
okay giganto Psy is very disrespectful
and I will tell you this it has the
adverse effect of what you think it does
because a giganto Psy means it's not an
effective P ussy because a lot of uh
people would like the tighter ones so
what you're saying is I'm not yeah but
that's now you're getting off the point
here what you're saying is I'm an
ineffective P ussy which means I'm brave
so thank you very much no got out of
that one yes got out of that one so dumb
I've thought about this and getting out
of that one bothers me so much when you
say get out of that one bothers me so
much you laugh at it so how do you feel
about that you laugh at it so it doesn't
bother you deep down so let's talk about
it how how does it make you feel
absolutely detested how does but then
why do you laugh at it yes got up to
that one you no it it says more about
you and who you are than anything else
imaginable yes does crushed you on that
one what what does the fact that you say
got out of that one when you're not even
in
one okay I was in one you weren't in one
you're never in one when you say got out
of that one you're never in one you're
just like we're talk what would be in
one predicament really and you're
cornered and like that's not what a
conversation is well I got of the
predicament using
using is my point using uh uh gymnastics
using linguistic G gymnastics I was able
to you know what I mean that the part
where uh Katherine Zeta Jones is doing
the thing in Entrapment where she's
trying to get through the laser beams
that's
me God so weird that that is the
enduring image from that and every time
I bring up ENT tratment that's what you
say this cuz I can't believe it though
also why do you bring up entrapment so
often well real question it was a movie
it was it honestly before that life was
good and then entrapment came out and
things really went to [__] but I will
say it entrapped you but I will say that
movie The reason why that happened was
because that was pretty sultry I know
but it's weird that that it's so weird
to me the things that become Touchstone
like uh enduring images of things okay
what else is one uh can we think of one
yeah I mean this was on my mind earlier
today so I don't know if everybody knows
it but the Exorcist the image of Max von
sidow outside the apartment and near the
light post that was the
poster yeah it was a post to that one
got Hollywood out of that one got
Hollywood out of that one you didn't you
weren't in one Hollywood was in one
Hollywood was in a predicament when you
said that
iname so uh yeah but that was the poster
yeah I guess it was I don't know if it
was the poster what the poster in was
heres it might as well be yeah yeah that
is weird how that stuff sticks in our
minds but maybe it's just us if we say
ENT trapment to someone else first of
all most people be like what the [__] is
ENT trp of like a movie and they be like
oh yeah that one was Sean Conor they
might not even know kather Zeta Jones is
in it you know what let's Google Images
see when the comes up okay scroll it's
going to be no don't put post the
posters doesn't yeah no poster don't
[__] it up like that movie just do movie
you got to put movie you got to do movie
you don't have to do movie I mean there
it is it's first page it's right there
was it really it's in the middle yeah
it's in the middle and keeps [__] it
up there is yeah yeah yeah there it is
the very first non- poster image was
that that's so weird what is it look how
many people have watch that well 2.16
million views and we get it we
understand why it's not because of the
plot it's because of her rious Maximus
yeah uh isn't that weird that's so how
much in all the Press photos how much
did Sean connory smell so bad and knew
it and made kathern Zeda Jones deal with
it and was just like put the chairs
closer he say dude and also how about
when he said he would hit women and he
should Walters was like yeah so what so
said yeah I still think that so dark you
know like the darkness in
that in in his memory his mind what's
flashing are like some of the darkest
moments ever you know when they're
talking about that I don't understand
how and and that that came out that they
were like trying to say [__] about him
when he was still alive and it just kind
of went away what do you mean say [__]
about him you know how the people
they'll be like oh you're canceled
because of this or whatever yeah but it
was people there's no like Rhyme or
Reason or or uh uniformity to that
working like people try to do that [__]
with many many people it doesn't work
you know true I guess you're right it's
just like some trains just keep rolling
and you're right you know just I wonder
if it affected Sean Conor at all you
know no no dude he's an outrageous
[__] is he yeah well obviously he
said that you yeah well yeah that I
don't even mean that do you know other
dick there are crazy stories about him
being just a giganto dick you can't now
you know what's weird is I know guys
that like stars that like are like that
that uh you know they're not my friends
but I know people that are dicks and
people think that they're great and they
don't know the real them and they're
such [__] [__] and it's crazy
that these people are not like get get
passes or or or or don't get exposed and
some people do and then some you know
what I mean it's like odd it's
completely so odd the idolatry of public
figures in general is stupid because the
chances of someone who's really really
famous and really really especially
really really powerful being a good
person are crazy low that's the thing
that I don't understand about how like
then they do the most the most most put
on a pedestal and beloved by people who
have no idea about them well that's the
thing I don't get about like Ellen or
like it's like oh you when remember when
it was comment that she's a big dick and
like she she's not going to do the show
anymore I don't know if she doesn't show
anymore but like but like oh your boss
is a dick yeah that oh your boss is a
dick The Ellen one was weird to me
because it was like she's just a a mean
boss every everyone is a mean boss yeah
paull the public I would I would guess
70% of people think their boss is a dick
yeah yeah and but guess what guess what
most of the time their bosses don't even
know they're being a dick they're just
the boss and they're like oh [__] really
I didn't know that [__] you yeah but
even that's immaterial because they're
being a dick and like the person under
them thinks so yeah it's just true
across the board it's so weird that was
a really weird one that was a weird one
but there were other ones too everyone
was like she's such a Monster who was
the one who did the the directed
The Who was the guy that directed the uh
uh he did some superhero movie oh James
gun no not him that was just for some
jokes he did on Twitter which was stupid
Brian Singer no let's be real about
James gun though he made too many jokes
like that but go on yeah okay but still
they were he was trying to be funny not
they were not funny very obvious that it
was a joke yeah no it was was it the it
wasn't Weeden was it oh Jos Weeden yeah
yeah dude the the thing on him I was
reading it I'm like nobody's even saying
anything specific
they were just like yeah he made me feel
bad I didn't read anything about him
because I don't care about him but
everyone does so yeah everyone cares
about him go go up go up go up go up
accused of
misogyny I I I I read it and I was like
I mean I I guess look I maybe I didn't
read the whole thing I don't remember
but I remember being like what is this
oh yeah he's mean somebody said he's
mean oh I remember this everybody was
like he's a huge dick and everybody came
out with stories about it yeah I mean
well look here's the thing I don't know
if you're a huge here's the ultimately
if you're a huge dick to everyone you
encounter you should expect there to be
a lot of people eventually it might
start to trickle out slowly at first but
eventually everyone's going to be like
that guy's a huge dick and it'll kind of
course correct so I get it that like
people want to let the world know that
their heroes are dicks that's fine with
me though anyway I just hope that they
reboot Buffy yeah well that's what the
conversation is all about okay let's do
another one uh all right yeah yeah yeah
way too long
hi Chris and Matt my name is Emily I'm a
huge fan Chris I've seen you in New
Hampshire and Boston and Matt we had a
private session because my mom was
dating a Que in honor which is no longer
happening so thank you oh uh so my issue
I am 33 I've been single for a long time
and would like to get back into dating
um after having done a lot of work on
myself I am now over a year and a half
sober from alcohol
and my struggle is that I don't know if
there's a right time to tell a guy about
my sobriety um and if there's a way to
frame it where it's not automatically
seen as a red flag I've been rejected a
lot I understand why a lot of people
would have addiction and alcoholism as a
deal breaker but um it would be nice if
I was given a shot any and all advice
would be greatly appreciated thank you
well it's up to you to help the stigma
though I mean like you can be an addict
and still you know there should be no sh
you have to you have to get to a point
where there's no shame in it you know is
she I'm sorry just for clarity is she
saying she'll tell people that she's
sober and they'll people will hold that
against her well I think I'm not I'm
actually that sounded like I was being a
wise ass there are people who are like
that and obviously the answer to that is
you don't need those people in your life
yeah those people suck dude but I think
to go beyond that she's talking about
the shame she has where she feels like
she has to bring it up and she doesn't
want people to have a certain reaction
to it and when should she bring it up
and I think that it
helps period it helps things if you just
drop the shame you learn how to drop
that and just say yeah I'm sober to
somebody it doesn't matter if first
second date whatever because it's just
it comes up when it comes up and if they
don't want you in your life like because
of that then they're doing you a favor I
I I I think that you know being an
alcoholic and being an addict is is
tough uh to navigate and you have to
come to grips with the fact that you're
okay you you you're a year and a half
sober that's amazing that's that's
actually a lot of time under your belt
you know I mean you're you're you know
yeah there's people who are sober for 20
years but you know it's uh it's a you're
doing a good job and you should be proud
of it yeah 100% exactly not not oh
what's this person going to think uh and
and and fur furore so many people are
addicts man like the people you tell
this to they don't even know they're
addicts in some way or another and
they're just saying you know but I I get
it I get the shame but like you you you
should just you need to work on get to a
place where it doesn't bother you
because I know as an addict that when
you let the
shame uh take you over it just spirals
you into more of a of an addict you know
of addict Behavior so
um yeah so work on a work on it to where
you're okay with yourself and [__] [__]
them dude if I me people yeah that but
but also about when to bring it up I
don't think you I think this kind of a
version of what you're saying but like
you don't there's no right or wrong time
bring it up when it comes up the first
time you guys are in a place where he
might be ordering a drink and you
don't explain it then just don't I don't
mean explain it like defend it just say
it I don't I don't drink and oh why oh
I'm sober I mean maybe I'm feel a
certain way about it because there's so
many sober people in La M maybe it's
different in other places in the country
yeah true it is that there's more of a
stigma but here dude it's so not
stigmatized no not at all at all but
also you also don't have to be make it
this thing where like hello I'm sober
this and that like you can just be like
oh yeah I haven't drank for a year and a
half I don't do that [__] anymore i'
[__] my life up you know what I'm saying
who wouldn't understand that yeah who's
got a thing about oh you don't here's
the thing you want to make the focus
about it I don't drink because I'm a
better person and healthier and wiser
and it's better for my life because I
don't not when I drink I get all [__]
up and it's this illness that I have
like no no no you don't drink because
it's a better decision for you not to
drink that's a a thing that everyone
should be seeking in a potential partner
they've weeded things out of their life
that make their life worse you have a
good think of it as like a badge of
honor not a badge of [__] well it is
yeah it is a bad that's what I'm saying
it is a badge of honor yeah period yeah
that's it um think of it that way and
when it does come up be proud to talk
about it I yeah if they don't like it
for sure [__] them why would you want
that person yeah yeah yeah even if
you're not sober and you're with
somebody that thinks that you don't want
to be with them that's a weird way to
think I think I think yeah I agree does
to solidified I do have a question for
um Mao actually and he just went to the
bathroom but he's coming back Mao yeah
you gave me an accessory to charge my I
phone you gave me this which is so so
big right can we agree Lifeline viewers
that this power pack is it's not just
big it's heavy
literally than my face it has a lot of
charges on I believe that cuz it's got a
lot of charges on it so that's great
okay I plugged it into my iPhone I I got
a charge I got a charge it was great it
was going well then I looked and down
and it said accessory has won't charge
the device because it has too much power
that's that's what it said your device
has too much power anymore it doesn't
say that oh it said that oh it said that
why would he why would he make that
up well I don't know if it's going to do
that again now because it's probably not
going to do it again now okay so when it
comes back I'll show you okay you're my
witness okay so I I'll keep it there
okay can't wait for it to do it again
being so loud it's no but it's can't
wait all right so let's do another one
okay hey Chris hey Matt Chris I saw you
in Salt Lake City a month
so absolutely wonderful show Matt I saw
a trailer for uh your movie and you look
like Christian Bale when you shave your
head in your face so uh know that okay
great I love you both I love the podcast
keep me going through my days thanks
brother so I got this thing where I work
with heavy equipment and I'll be
pinching my fingers sometimes and I get
a blood blister and I'll cut it so that
it doesn't stick on my skin looking all
gross and weird and [__] sure but I
didn't know if it was was weird because
I'm self Haring uh like an emo uh I want
to know you guys thoughts on that I love
the podcast keep ripping life ripping
appreciate you guys take
care uh 65% of men who live in Salt Lake
City look like that guy dude how crazy
is that look at him he's got the Salt
Lake City face I mean right there it
looks like Billy Bob Thorton in SL but
um yeah I don't know I I I that's not
self harm you know of course not but I
will say it's [__] fun as [__] why is
this so fun what is what is he talking
about he's saying he's got blisters and
they they they bulb up oh yeah okay yeah
and he pops them is that weird I thought
he said he cut Cuts them yeah yeah
popping them is cool why are you cutting
them well I think that that's you got to
you like heat the blade and then no is
that what he does you should right you
don't want to use some random blade it's
dirty and [__] yeah but I think what he
means does he means he actually cuts it
off I thought he no I think he cuts it
open and and let the juice which is
popping it let's the juice squeeze out I
mean this guy semantics and which is
popping it it's not popping it it's it's
what do you call that when you like
Lancing yeah yeah exactly yeah dude how
about that I am a Linguistics and I the
way I get out of [__] is unbelievable
that technically wasn't a yes got out Bo
but I would Lance it off I would Lance
it off if you boil I boil up with Fury
when you say I got out of Shakespeare I
but I feel my body welling up
Shakespeare hot oh body hot volcanic oh
body of mine boiling blood over the over
the hills I'm boiling um yeah I I don't
know I I I don't think it's weird I do
it and M man do I love it you love that
that love you drain it that's how you L
and then dra it I mean get a thesaurus
for [__] sake I didn't need one I did it
myself Fess where my thes guess where my
thesaurus is all right well stop would
you like to look look at look trying to
check if we have pants
on what does that say it says cannot use
accessory this accessory uses too much
power so what's it mean my phone's
[__] right here of course not that's
[__] now though cuz you just broke it
here here sorry why is that 28 lbs and
what what is that so what does that mean
it doesn't mean d nothing my accessory
uses too much power or his accessory
uses too much power who cares you're
saying that your phone's charged I no
it's not completely charged but it's
enough but what if it [__] it up and I
got to get a new iPhone dude just wipe
it off you'll never know it's already
gone wipe it off you know
hey no swipe it all right I get it swipe
it what uh Calvin would say swipe swipe
it off D he thinks it's skripe can you
sripe it that's cool it's so cute all
right um yeah I don't think it's weird
to land [__] off it's not weird at all
wait I did one recently what I do I I uh
oh I had a oh dude it didn't come
back what was it coming back I had a
thing all of a sudden I was like rubbing
my it hurts so bad and it was like a uh
a skin tag mhm oh yeah I came back
really I think so we don't talk about
this why'd you bring it up then well I
didn't want to now I didn't want people
to back yeah I feel it no no no no that
that that's not it that's that's not it
that's not it I had a different it
dude you know stop [__] so many times
I know that that I I was getting upset
and then the last time it's like I get
it I was just waiting for you to react
it was weird don't be like that dude I
caressed his neck [__] little brother
ass [__] I I caressed his neck
but it was weird though I know but you
took so many times to say it was weird I
thought it was interesting
anyway I I took it off cuz when I was at
the beach once no no the pool we were
out on vacation as as kids and oh it's a
long time ago yeah it was just me and
you we left Mom and Dad at home no we
went to we're at the pool and I had I
had this uh skin tag that was here I had
them all my life yeah and it was it was
falling off and as it was falling off I
was in the pool I just go I took it off
oh okay kind of that's what was hanging
out by a thread right and the next week
it was back it grows back you know that
right mhm right so I got it removed the
doctor got removed and so um this one
way little older than this one but all
of a sudden I'm like what the [__] what
is the how can you know what I'm saying
when you get older some [__] will just
appear like crazy weird yeah so I I it
was hanging on by a thread so I I
twisted a little it hurts so bad sounds
painful sounds gross too
like someone stabbed me so I'm like all
right [__] it so I get
the Kristen got me a nail clipper kit
hold thing all what are you doing okay
took the [__] sharpest Lance I go
like this gone no didn't hurt okay and I
just realized no it's not back it's not
back it's not back oh what the freak how
crazy is that it'll come back it'll come
back it'll be I'll wake up one day and
it'll be like my dresser you know why
though I feel stop if we've talked about
this already on the podcast it's in your
DNA to grow out of your body at a
certain time in your life and then if
you cut it off after it comes out your
body's still wired to have that so it'll
be like wait no you need that and regrow
it your body goes exactly no no no yep
um no yeah we did talk about that before
on this
podcast
okay so I got three moles removed though
when a month ago Dude oh yeah good I
that's good I when I was little I think
in I think again in fourth grade a lot
of fourth grade stuff coming up okay I
had a big mole removed from my back yeah
and I it was it was big enough to need
stitches I thought it was my our other
brother but okay we no I thought we had
three brothers but that was a mole oh
now you get it good job yeah okay that
one
and and I started showing people at
school and said well this is hilarious
actually I don't think I've ever told
you this I said the scar was from my
brother stabbed me in the
Back Shak so [__] symbolic how crazy
is that and people believe
Mears like that big you know would I
stab you with a toothpick why did nobody
say anything to me about it they were
scared of me that's why yeah they were
like why people were scared of me M's a
word when they came around dude I was PR
pretty much Tony Soprano dude pretty
much yeah and then there was that other
kid who said you were a drug dealer who
I beat up after school and lot lot a lot
of things said untrue about me so but
anyway let's do it let's do another one
yeah hi guys Chris Matt um called it
before Chris you remember my kitchen you
said it looks dope come over anyways um
I need help there's good friend of mine
her name is to be not announced anyways
um she's really
cool and I don't want to stop being
friends with with
her however she has sperm eyebrows you
know what those are MCO can you bring a
picture of sperm eyebrows I've I don't
bring up stuff anymore but nope you
don't look wrong [__] thing anyways
whatever uh their eyebrow literally
little ball and then Cho tail like a
sperm okay I'm not saying my eyebrows
are the best but okay uh sperm eyebrow
what do I do what do I tell her how do I
be like yo go get a microbladed yo well
let's see look up her sperm eyebrows
that's not a thing she made that Google
sperm eyebrows thanks love you Chris I'm
going to see you Sacramento
VIP let's see go can you Google it yeah
you can Google he's G to [__] see
what you type in you know this isn't
even going to be his fault I I I don't
think there's no such thing as a sperm
ey brow oh well that one looks like it
is that one looks like sper oh oh my God
that looks so much friend well that's
drawn on right of
course I never really oh oh oh it really
is a
thing oh my
God can you can you just go to like news
or something yeah news about sperm
eyebrows can you just go to like not the
pictures though I want to see if there's
like links sperm eyebrows like BuzzFeed
did something sperm eyebrow updates.com
can you go to Links can you just go to
all go to all not Lord Almighty dude why
would the [__] would do not want images
on that because I want to know if it's a
the story of sperm brows so now we know
it's a thing dude this guy really
doesn't get it huh early 2000 sperm
brows making a comeback it look sperm
brows it's a thing look listen it sounds
like sperm brows are a thing that people
do on purpose yeah that's what it does
sound so why would you tell your friend
that she has them she obviously knows
she's doing them on purpose that's crazy
this is a non thing to call in about you
don't tell it's like you don't tell
someone like hey do you know you just
got a haircut yeah they they got a
haircut cuz they got the haircut hey hey
uh you got sperm brows she I know oh
okay see movie exactly um but that's a
stupid thing that it's a thing honestly
that's a stupid thing because all
eyebrows kind of look like sperm anyway
that's a dumb thing that somebody made
up they all kind of look like sperm wait
what do who which group of people are
you saying are dumb though I'm confused
the people that do anyone that made up
that that thinks sperm brows is a real
thing no I totally get it no no no no no
I I understand but eyebrows are already
so on their way to look like sperms that
you can't be like these eyebrows it's
it's not it's like you know yes you can
though because no that's exactly why you
can because they look like flat things
that curve around your eyes I gu when
you shave like all but the little ends
but they look like balls it looks
exactly like a SP I understand but but
but maybe also people are just born with
it maybe she's born with it maybe it's
Maybelline maybe she's born with it
maybe it's sperm eyebrows
[Laughter]
maybe it's sperm
eyebrows yeah dude exactly but I I don't
I this is not this would be like hey my
friend has that step haircut that was
really popular in the '90s I get it I
don't know how to tell him he has a step
haircut and it's like you don't need to
tell him he got the step haircut I know
I got sperm brows done yeah hey dude you
got a shirt on yeah right yeah so
next
hi Chris hi Matt hi big fan of the
podcast my husband and I listen all the
time um so I'm currently four months
pregnant y do at the end of May great
and I have a friend from college which
was many years ago now um who's getting
married in June um she's asked me to be
a bridesmaid and um last time I talked
to her um you know she just wasn't
totally understanding that I'm expecting
to have a baby at the end of May and it
might be it will be really difficult to
be a bridesmaid and have a baby within
the same month um as you know due dates
are not set in stone so I could
potentially have a one to two week old
um and she's just not totally
understanding without me having to say
that I'm not confused looking for some
advice on how to approach that
conversation with her um and tell her
that it just doesn't feel possible to be
able to do both um any advice that you
have would be greatly appreciated thanks
okay cool I got great advice your friend
[__] sucks big chunky [__] Wow
first of all that street is really loud
outside your [__] friend you need to
move it is so loud on that street how
could your friend be so terrible as to
not understand why you wouldn't want to
be in their [__] wedding when you're
literally going to have a baby that day
I got one word that's conjoined brilla
okay next it's like I don't like to say
this but brilla okay I don't like when
you say it either yeah no I don't like
brilla at all but uh in this case it
people are well people get married their
this is the problem about weddings dude
when when women are like this is my
[__] day no it's not it's everyone
else's day too you're just happen to get
married on that day it's everyone else's
day [__] it's my day I have to go that
is infuriating my day too that is
upsetting yeah yeah that actually
there's nothing that would yeah you
would particularly be really infu so
something that would make me mad did so
congrats yeah uh yeah just say no dude
say no that's too much on your F Glee
dude she no she said she did say no and
her friend was like not understanding I
understand but keep to the no is what
I'm saying I mean I should [__] hope
so right I think she's more saying like
why did like what do I do about my
friend not understand it yeah that's not
cool you have a baby do on yeah what she
like hold she's just like hold it in
your [__] yeah what does she expect you
to what is the solution even I do she's
up like sh yeah water just dripping down
her leg Yeah KN cuz KN cuz on there cuz
she's having a
baby cuz that happens to me how that is
like Peak selfishness think about it
yeah it is that's crazy Peak
selfishness Peak selfishness because
it's not even just about it's about the
lady it's about the also the baby you're
ruining a a bunch of stuff so many
stuffs I imagine you were born at my
friend's wedding I couldn't say no
to I had to I sorry dude sorry yeah I
had to hold it because I had to make
sure that you know I printed out her
vows making her feel so bad and [__] cuz
of this dude come on
yeah yeah that that's Tre was loud huh I
really it was getting to me that you
were doing that you know yeah I know but
uh I think lay just going to lay it out
there it was getting to me I think it
was good in fact I missed the first one
and that's what pissed me off because
here's the thing I saw the first one go
by I was about to do it and I was like I
shouldn't do it and then I got upset I
didn't do it so then I did every single
car after that secret
and then when I was delighted when I saw
cars go this way too I was like oh cool
and then I saw one make a turn and I go
delighted I did it yeah okay you got
it's the small wins in life you know I
agree with that but that was a loss it's
the small wins in life and I won there
that was a that was a net loss it was a
gross win cuz you're going to learn
about loss what's that what is that from
it a gross win I don't even know what
it's from it's from a movie oh oh you're
going to learn about that's from Kate
fear H you're dark um all right
all right next
one what's up Matt what's up
Chris see this I will be 6 months sober
um I had a very bad alcohol problem um
and that led me to move home to get some
help temporarily so I'm staying with my
parents um good for you and through the
time at home I've noticed something that
my dad does it drives me absolutely
insane um so my mom buys ice cream she
buys it she doesn't eat it she buys it
for me and my dad to share it's like a
communal ice cream okay well that sounds
like a Zack movie and we both eat out of
the carton now my dad likes chocolate
syrup I sometimes like it most of the
time I I know what's going on my dad
will pour the chocolate syrup into the
carton of the ice cream instead of
putting it in a bowl inexcusable and
that ruins it for
meable most of the time I don't want it
so when I go to open it there's
chocolate syrup all over the place says
there's not but there is oh I like this
because I'm looking at it um now I need
him to know that it's an extremely
inconsiderate thing to do um and if he
wants the chocolate syrup he should be
putting it in a bowl yeah but he doesn't
think that he should be putting it in a
bowl because he says oh well it's you're
not going to notice it I eat all of it
and he doesn't and I've seen that so
that's AR you don't where do you guys
fall on this and how do I get him to
understand that this is something he
should not be doing to his son uh Chris
I'll see you January 20th at celebrity
theater in Phoenix life rips hell yeah D
chris.com for dude hey how about this
use bows you [__] heathens yeah
here's here's the main thing though how
do you convince him like show him show
him the chocolate syrup in the in the
car you mean you don't like he doesn't
believe it I know what's happening it's
not that much and and the dad's just
like of course yeah so it's like I get
what the Dad's doing but use Bulls you
heathens D you're two different people
yeah yes exactly share it you share it
you know you share it heathens and also
um chocolate syrup is gross sucks bro
you're [__] disgusting father you're
a [__] disgusting father fat [__] and
honestly disgraceful that you use it
sometimes you Heathen and here's another
thing that you could always pull you you
say to your dad oh you know what you you
do it again you put chocolate sauce on
the thing I'm going to start drinking
again
great it be on you my life's on you as
you walk
away and then the next day show up so
drunk you know what interesting
congratulations on your sobriety though
these kinds of things are often like
yeah but yeah but da da D well but it
could be that da no that's not what this
is your dad is plain ass wrong plain old
plain ass dead ass wrong I'm liking it
okay I don't like anything about this so
now what you're going to do is make sure
that he uses a bowl from here on out
okay or give your mom you cheap ass [__]
a little bit of money to buy two ice
cream Fair have one that is yours and
one that is his him yeah yeah but when
he does then you'll have even more of a
legitimate gripe your dad is [__]
everything up won't matter though but
give your mom a few extra bucks to get
two of them okay no that's the answer is
use blls obviously but it's cost
effective but it's obviously not going
to be done by the father [__] I'm angry
yeah that's the point so we got to work
you know what I would do honestly when
the ice cream came I would take half of
it out and put it in a bowl in the
freezer wow you're crazy I would that's
crazy though it it needs to be done it's
a necessity and when I would do it I
would go like this yes got to of that
one yeah you would do that because dude
it's like God chocolate syrup sucks so
bad why does he want chocolate syrup on
his ice cream it's fine you like what
you like but ice cream comes already
done it's finished so sweet it's so
sweetly flavored and so nice it's
finished completely finished tested the
taste of it I I I I know I dude you're
talking to me bro and they put the thing
in the cart and it's done I don't even
like cranberry sauce on Thanksgiving
dinners I get it dude yeah it's done I
want everything all aart so when I can
you know me right I have met you yeah so
it's like I got the Brownie and the ice
cream I think the brownie I do out how
much ice cream on I want out the brownie
you don't put don't you dare put the
[__] ice cream on the brownie that's
different n it's not different dude I'll
tell you why it's not different too
because the ice cream melts all over the
brownie cuz the brownie hot dude guess
what I'm in the restaurant don't even
[__] microwave the brownie I'll
decide thank you very much you'll decide
what the heat the temperature and how
much ice cream gets doled out on the
brownie at a at a restaurant how you're
going to go in the back Indian chief um
I going to go in the back no no no I say
I would like dude I go to this
restaurant sometimes I don't and they
get they have a a
brownie and and the nerve of these
[__] man you order to the
Brownie and they say okay great you
don't say anything they bring it with
[__] whipped cream ice cream nuts
[__] it says brownie so I say it
doesn't say under it comes with so I say
brownie I want the brownie don't heat it
up and then I want ice cream on the side
of it uhuh and it comes Bing Bang Boom I
got the way I want it okay okay that's
the end how but you said you sounded mad
that's the good
ending it's infuriating that people
think brownie comes with everything oh
yeah yeah that's here's another one hey
oh dude this drives me [__] why do
people put a [__] line in club soda
or
water here's the worst part you don't
think that's bad well let me grind your
gears okay would you like a would you
like a line that they just ask that
right yeah no thank you yeah great
that's how it should be you're saying
right no that's what they do oh okay
they go Club guy at the bar just puts
the on here now you're we're getting
into territory you ask me some [__] I
didn't I had to answer it shouldn't even
be on there period cuz I just asked for
a club soda if I want a lime on it I
should say hi I'd like a club soda with
lime if I just said club soda don't ask
me about lime but if you're going to ask
me about lime and I say no connect with
the bartender on it
MH yeah I completely agree I didn't
think you're going to agree no of course
I agree well I mean if they ask you do
you want something you say no and they
bring it to you and it comes with the
thing you specifically said you didn't
want I know I know then there's no you
could have said it's not a big deal but
there's no opinion there it's just is a
plain fact that obviously it shouldn't
come with the line I know I know all
right let's do another one all
right so H what's up fellas my name is
Hans I live in Anchorage Alaska um
that's Southern Alaska not northern
Alaska one cares however many weeks ago
Chris mentioned how people in northern
Alaska may not find anybody you know
or what um I did find somebody my fiance
is from Alaska however we did meet in
Boise so there's that you know but I
just wanted to mention that CU you know
maybe our Oklahoma girl there's some
hope for her you know I found found love
all the way up here in Alaska so anyways
I'm just call on though with some some
questions um I'm getting married this
Summer nice uh and I know my opinion
does not matter and I'm okay with that
th% okay with that however my fiance
still wants input
yeah how do I go about that you know
planning for a wedding that's my
question but knowing your your you know
opinion or or input isn't really going
to be taken seriously I I'm not offended
by it but she still asks all the time I
know I want to be involved but it's like
her day she's going to get what she
wants that's my question guys you're
awesome and hello from Alaska man
apprciate here's how it goes you say
look I'm 100% happy to give you my
opinion on options but I'm not going to
generate any ideas for it because
they're just going to get shot down and
why waste either one of our well he's
precious time so what what you should do
is do pull together your ideas and then
you know as like a sub whatever of your
ideas options about those ideas and I
will pick the things I'll put my vote
forward but I'm not going to be
generating any ideas about this stuff
nor do I think I should that should all
be from her and then you get your input
you tell you know you have your voice
heard about the options she provides you
with but I think that he's talking about
when she asks him a question yeah not
necessarily generating ideas I think
she's like like I took it as hey what
color do you want the napkins this one
or this one yeah that's what it should
be what do you mean that's what I'm
saying because I think bro cuz women
will still be like you'll be like oh I
like this one they be like nah I'm going
to go with this one that's crazy well
then here's the
advice say okay yeah don't care if you
don't care then what do you care yeah
that's the thing if you know if you
don't care a and you have no problem
with your voice being drawned out by
hers what's what is even the problem how
to act this is how you act hey honey you
know I we want the tablecloth but we
don't know if we want this color or that
color what do you think oh I want that
color and she says oh no actually I
think this color is better you say oh
yeah that color is great too you
finished you finished it all congrats
you're done I don't know you go like
this I like this you like this color I
like this oh really I like this color
cool I'm not marrying
you or that yeah I don't um
yeah I don't know uh I think it's fine
and marriage is less about you know I
think wanting
to you know I mean you you say
oh W give up G no but you look at your
house and you're like oh how much of
this did I decorate zero you know and
then it's like I don't care actually
yeah I think that's the the the the the
dude it's so good for everybody and this
is a recommendation to every everyone
men and women and everybody in between
okay the more things you don't care
about in your relationship the better
off your life and your partner's life
will be yeah that is true so anytime you
realize the sneaking suspicion oh wait a
second oh wait oh I don't give a [__]
about this roll with that stick with
that go with that because it's good for
both of you it's good for business
everyone's going to be happier mhm so
stick with that that that is man and
woman's best friend
yeah it's a dog but yeah good for
business no man and woman's yeah right
okay after dog it's man and woman's best
friends so dog's men's best friend
second best friend to man not caring
about the relationship well no dog is
man's best friend not caring is men and
woman's best friends different categor
not caring okay so a a best friend is
man how about single man's best friend
is a dog best friend in a relationship
if it's a if you're a guy is not caring
about the Rel what what the woman wants
in a relationship and letting it slide
taking it so seriously but if you have a
dog in the relationship then the dog
goes to moves to second right M yeah
okay okay great that's fine are we done
I would say yeah well you know what
honestly I think we're done with the
that could be it that could be the last
one that's that is literally the
last sub submission of the Year 2023 oh
wow yeah that that was okay I will say
that's the that that's not uh for last
submission in 2023 is horrible
it was horrible but guess
what it gives it makes the bar for next
year lower and we're going to top it You
Raise Me Up you raise the bar
[Music]
up um Josh groin for some reason I can't
sing it so I'm not going to try I I to
the tune of You Raise Me Up I think and
sing sometimes to myself the lyrics You
braze my
beef no reason at all we better not end
the year on that sing you braze my beef
and that'll be the end you you braze my
beef see it's good dude wait you've
always thought this for some reason I
just think you braze my beef you braze
my beef there you go see that's a great
note to end are you kidding me that's
tippy top [__] what do you call those
um uh pressure in a beautiful pressure
cooker you bra my beef I I don't even
know if you're bra beef in a pressure
cooker I have no idea nobody knows
anything nobody even knows what the word
braze means even chefs that's not true
yes it is dude if and if you prove me
wrong right now it's over braise my
braise your
hand uh all right well look uh Happy New
Year tomorrow Happy New Year tomorrow
and get those tickets dude uh I will be
in Albuquerque and El Paso and
Sacramento and Brea and Houston and uh
Phoenix and all sorts of places Corpus
chrisy I'm going to be in for some
reason
uh Kona Vancouver and go watch grow or
die you know what go to chris.com get
grow or die watch it tomorrow watch it
on the 1 would be a great way to start
your year that's my new special um and
then come see me on tour see all new
stuff watch the special and then see all
my new stuff thank you very much and
also subscribe to Lifeline luxury yes
patreon.com back SL is it SL patreon.com
Lifeline luxury the second best show in
the world first show first best show in
the world being this show Lifeline my
pod my solo podcast the private record
is coming out real soon go to the
private record.com to submit yourself as
a potential guest on that show follow us
on Instagram Tik Tok subscribe on
YouTube you want to one1 with me you
want to one1 one11 one1 with me go to
mata.com book an advice session now and
of course if you want the great Lifeline
merch go to Lifeline
merch.com all good happy New Year we
will see you all in 2024 oh yeah you
brace my
beef
hello
[Music]
hello hello